welcome back to Las Vegas Christina Pink
here with Charlotte's first round pick
and number two overall pick Brandon
Miller so they had you shut it down
after probably a breakout performance
here in Vegas with 26 points but overall
how would you evaluate your summer
league performance
um it was definitely fun you know just
being here um just playing with my
teammates have as much the most fun as
it can with them just building new bonds
with them I think that's the most
important thing just being here building
new bonds with everybody seeing
everybody spend some weaknesses
how are you hoping to fit in with the
Hornets it's a season
um I think it'd be a great fit I know we
have lamelo ball which is great IQ with
my ability to knock down shots and that
can go a long way now you talked about
having fun with some of your teammates
you've had some funny interviews funny
sound bites that have been all over one
was the goat debate between LeBron and
Jordan you said your goat was Paul
George now I know you got a chance to
meet ear goat PG here in Vegas what
happened
um I met him I did one of his podcasts
we definitely just chopped it up for a
minute after the podcast but I mean it's
PG man it's my goal like I said
um so it's kind of an exciting moment
just to meet him and be in his presence
I feel like we built a bond and I we
swapped the infos now I look at him as
an older brother
now you also made some waves so over the
last couple of days with a tick tock
video that was circulating you didn't
know who Chris Middleton was tell me
what happened
um I don't know who Chris Middleton is
um you know I think I think I think
people should have more fun
um in the NBA instead of just you know
always serious uh I think I can bring
the the fun back to the game now he did
tell did tell me guys beforehand that he
was intentionally trolling right yes I
showed the media for fun
um so if you know if you take it you
know laugh at it you know don't don't
don't don't be don't be that guy about
it just you know laugh at it maybe
repost it you know I'll repost it if you
repost it all right thanks so much for
your time Brandon back to you guys
thank you Christina thank you Brandon so
another